all right house Speaker Kevin McCarthy
clearly touched a big nerve on the left
when he announced the beginning of an
impeachment inquiry into President Joe
Biden yesterday the Democrats they did
not take it very well this is shocking
take a look
extreme Mega Republicans have launched
an illegitimate impeachment inquiry that
is a kangaroo court
fishing Expedition and conspiracy
theater rolled into one
there is not a shred of evidence that
President Joe Biden has engaged in
wrongdoing but I it's an interesting
fact the murder capital of California is
Kevin McCarthy's District
it's a murder capital of California
consistently year in year out I just
think that's interesting I mean give me
a break
this is student government
house Speaker Kevin McCarthy joins us
right now Mr Speaker how are you
you're welcome
well
I kind of we've been following the story
very closely I can give you chapter
verse in detail but you know it as well
as I do and yet they just claim that
there's no evidence at all is it normal
for a vice president we know in October
2015 it became official Obama
administration policy to that Ukraine
had made enough progress on the issue of
corruption that they through an
interagency agreement agreed that it was
time to give them one billion in loan
guarantees okay it was Joe Biden's job
to give that to them uh okay five days
before his trip to Ukraine he got on the
phone with barisma Executives and his
son Hunter at a time that Barista
Executives the saying and begging they
needed help they needed help in D.C DC
help and anyway five days later he goes
to Ukraine that's when he leveraged one
billion of our taxpayer dollars
demanding a prosecutor get fired and as
a result of that decision his son
continued to get paid for a job in which
he admits he had no experience uh and he
got paid a fortune and we're talking
about tens of millions of dollars never
mind the shell corporations never mind
the grandkids getting paid so no
evidence that sounds like a lot of
evidence to me
that's just something the other part you
didn't put it the money that he got for
Hunter Biden being on the board he never
declared it but what did the Biden
Administration do the doj they let the
statue of limitations run out with the
IRS which the IRS would never allow you
to do you know remember why Hunter Biden
what he told why he's on that board he
said he had no experience he was there
because it was part of the Biden brand
you know you can tell exactly what's
happening at the White House the bidens
have given the marching orders to the
media they know that they do not want to
provide the information to the American
people and the American people deserve
it that is exactly why I did impeachment
inquiry it empowers Congress from the
Republicans and Democrats to be able to
get the answers to all these questions
from the informant that told the FBI
that that he alleges that there was a
bribe to the Biden family to the when
you find that he used different names
and emails where he actually talked with
his own office sending to Hunter Biden
as well about Ukraine then when you look
at when he told the American public he
never had any dealings with his son or
talked about in this business but he
goes to meetings think for one moment
did he know when he went to dinner his
son would get a new Porsche did he know
when he went back to Cafe Milano for
another dinner more than three million
dollars would go to an another shell
company these are all questions that
deserve to be answered and we got to
remember Mr Speaker he said over and
over again not one time never did he
ever talk to his son hunter or his
brother or anybody for that matter said
it as a candidate multiple times as
president multiple times about their
foreign business dealings and yet you're
right he's meeting with Russian oligarch
and Kazakhstan oligarchs he's on you
know according to Devin Archer 20 calls
he they talk about the Biden brand I
don't think the Biden brand was Hunter
do you believe that we're looking at
potentially then vice president now
President Biden was involved in quid pro
quo this for that bribery and with the
shell corporations do you see that
potentially as money laundering
look there are allegations out there our
role there are enough allegations the
president has changed what he has told
the American public so what we believe
is you see a culture of corruption we
are going to get the answers to these
questions I think the President should
want to help us if I was accused of this
I would want to come forward remember no
one would know of any of this
information had the Republicans not
taken the majority and remember what
else we found out you know we found out
now that he actually has a staffer that
worked in the White House that actually
went back to Hunter Biden's workers and
said the president has approved the
talking points on barisma how can you do
that if you've never talked to your son
about it you've watched he used his own
Administration the doj to treat his son
differently remember these IRS agents
who came forward well you know what when
they talk about the phone call where
Weiss actually told them that he
couldn't that he had to go higher up
that they didn't couldn't be the special
prosecutor they could couldn't prosecute
well now you have the Attorney General
in a box who told the American public in
Congress something different we need to
know who lied in this situation because
there have been new people who've come
in and you just had Jason Smith the ways
and means chairman on your show last
night who just clarified that other
people actually told the same story
about the IRS agents of what was said
that night all right we we have a lot of
issues this seems to be conflict I know
Congressman Matt Gates has brought up
the issue of possible vacating the chair
issues and I asked very specifically
what what are the items that you are
most concerned about and uh he says he
and others want individual
Appropriations bills and the time is
running short on that a balanced budget
vote and a term limit vote are those
votes coming
yeah but we've been trying to do
individual appropriation bills we tried
one today but the rule wouldn't pass and
this was about defense this was about
giving our our military men and women a
pay raise but it was the those
Republicans holding up I don't think
that's the real problem that Matt's most
concerned about unfortunately Matt had
an Ethics complaint against him in the
last Congress he thinks he can use this
to try to influence I'm never going to
influence an independent committee and
I'm not going to put a swallow back on
the Intel committee so if he works with
those two I'm only going to work for the
American public and get the answers for
them well I've said at the beginning
that I think Republicans you're either
going to succeed together or fail
together with the majority you have I
stand by that
um Mr speaker thank you sir appreciate
it hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else